came up with this idea called Mono
thinking after I read a quote from a
friend you can gauge someone's Ignorance
by the number of phenomena they explain
with the same answer those who blame
many different issues like War poverty
and pollution on just one cause
capitalism are recycling explanations
because their demand for answers
outstrips the supply it's another
explanation for me about why people who
are not extremist cookie cutter
ideologues get criticized an awful lot
if I know one of your views and from it
I can accurately predict everything else
that you believe you're not a serious
thinker you have adopted a onesie
wholesale and you've decided to put this
on the advantage from a group scenario
is that I can very accurately predict
what you're going to think about the
next thing because it's what everyone
else is going to think about the next
thing the disadvantage of being someone
who doesn't take their ideology
wholesale you basically become an
unreliable Ally yeah sure you're with us
on abortion but what about Donald Trump
you weren't with us on that so what
about when the next thing happens I
actually know if we should trust Steven
so much and it's not an actual thought
but it's just something that sits in the
back of their mind